so let's jump in kind of right at the
beginning of all of this because as an
x-men fan of been teased before I my
hair today and what I hoped was the best
Dark Phoenix style I could very good job
thank you my name is grey also I get
really mad sometimes spelled right your
last name but it's close enough thanks
for pointing that out and and so what
made this the moment to finally give
this storyline its own self a lot of
things I think one the climate for these
kinds of movies allows for the drama the
intensity the character driven nature of
what a dark phoenix story needs to be
after we get Logan after all the
different things that are happening in
the genre now and we felt like after the
last x-men movie in May apocalypse which
was huge and scale and scope we wanted
to actually tell the story they could do
that but could really be also into at
the same time and the dark phoenix story
is this intimate story about as you know
and you all know a central character in
jean who starts to lose control and
that's all it is really it happens to
manifest as superpowers and huge
destructive ways but it is about someone
who loses control the people who love
her some of them want to save her some
of them want to save the world from her
and so it fractures this family around
her as she herself is fracturing so for
me as a writer as an artist as a
filmmaker telling that story after Logan
telling that story after we had gone
huge on apocalypse it just felt like the
right time to tell it that as a somebody
who has visited these movies in the
theater since they were starting in the
2000s I think that what keeps being
exciting for me is that they all feel
different like that's the secret to the
sequel and so hutch especially when
you're considering
you're mentioning Logan Simon when
you're considering something like Logan
could you would you liken this Dark
Phoenix story to anything else like is
there or if not what kind of sub-genre
of movie would this belong to because we
already I mean I can kind of tell it's
not read based on what you guys are
gonna see in a minute
it's not what it's not just an action
accident that they yeah no I don't know
that I would liken it to any other movie
that I can think of and I guess it'd be
a weird mix between a family drama and
to some degree I guess a science fiction
story and you've got elements of both
but as you point out I mean it's very
clear to us who won the other like
material to all of this you know to the
x-men universe is pretty incredible and
for all the character based reasons the
sign was saying but also because the
thematics are so rich they're so
powerful they've been relatable and
important so with that you feel an
obligation to try to to reach deeper
into the material and and I think
assignment alluded to this there's a lot
of great work being done in this arena
and and the table felt like it had been
well set to do what Simon has long
wanted to do which is to do a kind of
deep dive on Dark Phoenix and do it more
thoroughly and more substantively and
with with much more detail and nuance
and that was exciting to all of us to
the actors to to myself I think
certainly in a Fox so you know kind of
came up organically I guess that's why I
keep when I think about what we've seen
of this so far which is way too little
by the way you guys just a note I always
go back to Logan because
so personal because you know my husband
was crying do not tell him that I told
you that but it's a it's such an
emotional story so when you're working
with the studio did doing the huge
apocalypse movie like pave the way for
this they were like yeah man you can
make this one like more of a family
drama um they're very trusting of us in
general because we've made so many of
these movies now so they they like when
we Zig after weaves act on these films
and I think Logan helped pave the way
actually and the other part of this film
and you'll see some of it and what we're
going to show you is that what Marvel
Studios has done in terms of making
these movies extra-terrestrial taking
them into space some guardians with or
ragnarok with the Avengers movies
allowed for us to tell the Dark Phoenix
story not just in the dramatic grounded
emotional ways that we're talking about
that Logan does but to also go to outer
space to also have alien characters and
I think that's why when touch was when
you asked touch what the genre is it's
tough to to pinpoint what it is because
it is a combination of something like
Logan that is a drama I mean a western
but really a drama and something that is
larger and more cosmic for lack of a
better description it is it is truly
science fiction Jessica Chastain plays
an alien character in the movie and
there are scenes that in outer space and
you couldn't have had that in Logan you
couldn't have an ex jet in Logan nobody
wears uniforms in Logan so it is a
larger canvas than something like Logan
but in its intention it has that kind of
intensity and that kind of emotionality
and I hope that it makes your husband
cry would you like to set up what you
brought for everybody today sure perfect
segue okay sorry
right I don't know if it'll make her of
this part of my costume cracks it's
early in the movie um you guys are the
first to see actual continuous footage
from this film we're going to show you
about I think 13 14 minutes and it is
early in the film at the beginning of
the movie the x-men are the x-men that
I'm sure a lot of you know from the
comics where they are actually known to
the world and actually for lack of a
less generic term superheroes and you
see them on a mission and see part of
what starts to create the fracture in
Jean so it's got big action it's also
got the drama the emotion in it the only
things I will say in addition that don't
fill in on your phone um you heard
already is that the visual effects are
obviously not finished and movie hasn't
come out until next summer
um but they will give you a sense of
what it will look like the music is
composed by Hans Zimmer yeah I forgot
which of the TC movies that he would
never do another superhero movie and we
convinced him to do this and the big
part of why we convinced him is because
of the drama that we're talking about
but even that music is not finished and
it isn't recorded the way that it'll be
ultimately recorded so just know that
you're seeing a movie in process but you
are seeing a big chunk of that movie in
process
Sophia official blanket apology just in
case I accidentally ever go hey Jean
but at what point were you told that
this is going to be dark Phoenix
therefore centering on your character
finally the finally it was from the fans
I was I was told about six months before
we started shooting the movie Simon kind
of took me to lunch and sat me down and
and told me what the movie was going to
be they was gonna be dubbed Phoenix what
that meant or they're meant for
preparation and luckily he gave me
enough time to prepare but it was a big
undertaking and a lot of pressure but
also such an honor because I know that
the fans are so in love with a storyline
and and I really think that we did it
justice let's bookmark the preparation
that you did don't let me forget about
going back to that but tie down there at
the end when we're telling the story
about Jean we're also telling the story
about you as well
you know about Scott and I'm just gonna
keep saying you cuz you guys are these
people
so what so when you first read the
script you know I know there's not a lot
that you can necessarily reveal but
where was the emotion for you I think I
was just excited that we were taking a
crack at something that was a bit more
grounded and a bit more human if you
will even though we're all mutants but
it was just it was really exciting
because as you can see I mean this is
pretty early on in the movie and that's
kind of the central you know instance
where things start to change one when
you see what just happened in space but
um yeah I think after things start to
unravel throughout the film you know
suddenly my character is encountering
he's lost the love of his life and she's
you know she's lost control of herself
and you know that's a really hard thing
to grasp a swallow and so I think it
even splits the x-men up so you know so
there's a lot of conflict in this movie
between the x-men and I think that
there's so you see a bit of fragility
that you haven't seen it's got in the
past and some of these films and that
was really exciting for me hutch can you
talk about how right now might be the
perfect time for us to finally have the
story like socially like it on it on a
larger scale because you kind of can't
ignore that kind of thing now we're so
information flows so freely
yeah I think that's part of what makes
these movies so resident in general
specifically the x-men movies is because
they deal so directly with alienation
and and prejudice and issues that
certainly seemed inescapable the news
these days and it's no accident I think
that Simon wanted to tell the story and
and has empowered the female characters
in this story in the ways that he has
which is not it's not to say politically
it's just just a natural cultural
instinct and then that's part of what
you
I'll say this producer is that you look
for in your filmmakers are people who
who can see in the underlying material
the possibilities to both create
relatable circumstances as human beings
but also create relatable metaphors for
what's happening in the culture and and
this story is uniquely powerful in that
regard I would I would say that the
choice Simon made in terms of how how
he's told this story is perhaps even
more so yeah I think that's what good
sci-fi does so you reflect your real
world and helps you understand more
about it through a story that might be a
little more palatable
perhaps Oh can't wait and finally here
and you're directing yes yes it was
great fun and you know I've been writing
and producing for many many years now
and it worked with lots of different
kinds of filmmakers not just in the
x-men movies but they have spanned from
filmmakers that needed an immense amount
of help and so I got to sort of which
ones tell us everything
much of it is on record already so you
just just google it um no but but I've
got to sort of practice direct on some
big feature movies with directors who
let's say we're very collaborative and
then I've also got so just sit back and
watch people like Ridley Scott and Ken
brought up and Guy Ritchie and Matthew
Vaughn and lots of great filmmakers who
treated me like a partner and at the
very least allowed me to be present for
the process so I learned a lot I mean I
learned a lot from watching Ridley
direct especially the way he interacted
with the actors the respect he had for
them and the way he was collaborative
with them especially for someone like
that who doesn't need to be
collaborative with anybody because he's
Ridley Scott and yet he understands that
he's part of what's so great about
making movies is and especially when you
get to make them with with great people
and you know the best of the best you
have an opportunity to take all of that
talent harness it together and create
something that's
greater than anything you could have
done on your own and with this cast
especially if I came to you and said I
have a drama or a comedy or any kind of
movie or science fiction movie with Ty
Sheridan and sophie Turner and Jessica
Chastain and Jennifer Lawrence's Michael
Fassbender James McAvoy and nickel you'd
be like that's the greatest cast ever
and they're in a superhero movie so I
didn't I
for me what was exciting about directing
in addition to just being able to create
the tone of the set and the tone of the
movie which i think is in some ways the
the biggest responsibility of the
director is creating tone was to play
with these actors in a different way and
to really get in there and collaborate
with them and sort of tailor lines to
them listen to their Cadence's and the
way that they spoke and find their
strengths and and play to them so real
talk then having been in another x-men
movie how was the experience different
this time around with Simon as the
director kind of working with you and
taking taking me performance apart and
building it up in this particular way
just pretend like he's not here
definitely much more engaged focused all
around is not it does it's non-existent
when you're shooting it you know it's a
perhaps an effect late or something like
that I'm sure it helps yeah sometimes
but I think a lot of times you know your
that this story is so grounded and you
know drama that it's that's what it's
about you know so it's an eighth in the
script and in the writing and you know I
think for for us it was just nice to
have someone guiding us and leading us
and it's it's a big movie you know you
really need somebody who can really hone
in on the vision and be really specific
about every little detail because if you
get one element that's not right you
know some
I think starts a kind of wonder off
kilter and I think in this film you know
Sami did such a great job and there's a
first time director and it's crazy to me
to think that you know he he
accomplished what he did in this in this
film and we all we all believed in him
so much you know they don't think there
was ever a doubt from any of the career
the cast you know it was from day one it
was like you know you're back in this
guy when you're he could do it so yeah I
was just it was it overall I think this
film was much much more much more
pleasing to make that makes sense i I
think that audiences pick up on things
like if if there was a day when you
maybe didn't ask all the questions about
the script or you didn't see if that
felt true to you that's the kind of
stuff that sitting in the seats were
like wow you know like it comes across
so it's cool it's cool to think that
this is a little bit more of a micro
focused style so that kind of winds back
to preparation in seeing this clip again
one of the things that fascinates me is
a non actor is that like I just said a
lot of this stuff doesn't exist yet when
you're doing it and so you're really
doing a lot of heavy lifting in the
acting department so can you talk
something about how you prepared for
this and like I'm talking like even
nitty-gritty like this is the kind of
stuff that I I'm I'm speaking for all of
us again like I want to know it's like
your own AO cosmic rays are flowing
through your body it's like that cosmic
rays girl wave on a lot
whether microwave just let it flow then
I go scream at my mom for a while but
like sorry mother Phoenix
don't know I mean preparation wise Simon
and I were going back and forth back and
forth back and forth for months with we
mainly study is kind of schizophrenia
and multiple personality disorder when
you see the movie or if you read the
comic don't know why and we kind of went
back and forth with material like that
just educating ourselves and for about
two days straight and had this son that
my headphones and I was listening to
this YouTube thing and it was like what
it what it sounds like and what it feels
like to be schizophrenic and so I would
walk around and try and do my daily
chores of jobs and run my errands with
voices in my head all day which was
really interesting and I got nothing
done and then before we used after the
movie I mean we we had like two weeks of
just like straight rehearsals for hours
and hours and hours a day just I mean it
wasn't even rehearsals it was just
talking over like every single line of
the script and the dialogue and the
action and I'm really like honing in and
making sure it was what we both felt
like it needed to be and that's the
thing about Simon he's so so
collaborative and so when you say you
know if there's something that didn't
feel right to you it comes across to the
audience but I think for all of us by
the time that we started shooting this
movie we knew that everything in that
script felt bright and felt justified
and so that was just such a gratifying
experience to do that with with Simon
the most collaborative most wonderful
director you reimagine that you really
need that because it's acting in its
best form is very vulnerable
to begin with but especially when you're
taking on a certain responsibility you
know when you're training a character
and when you're studying mental illness
like that that's something that's going
to be reaching everyone so yeah
absolutely and I mean mental illness
means means a lot to me personally and
so it even more importantly to me I felt
like this movie you know so often you
can see superhero movies they can
sometimes be a bit like gimmicky and
like we sleep in here but this is a
great impression but this I felt like
because it it does kind of relate so
much to the mental illness world that I
really felt that everything had to be a
very respectful version of what it is
and not make it feel gimmicky and it
never it never does I don't think and
that's what I love about this script as
though even though there's that kind of
escapism and you have the superhero
elements the fantastical elements not
once does it kind of make fun of it or
or make it lighter than it is it's it's
very real and I love that about this
movie is it's kind of heartbreaking but
it's it's beautiful yeah it seems so far
just seeing that little bit it can work
on those levels because you know I just
need to mention for my own edification
that your eye shadow is banging in that
clip for any of you out there that care
about that kind of stuff that my right
yeah it's yes we're getting a lot of
applause for the makeup and going back
to rehearsal Simon is there a member in
the cast maybe that couldn't be with us
here today that you find is like
especially collaborative and kind of
excited in in that those early stages to
talk through stuff I mean they were all
really excited because I'm movies at
this scale for whatever reason it should
be the opposite but on these big movies
you get the least rehearsal time on
independent movie in a smaller movie you
get more rehearsal time partly I guess
because you have less shooting time so
you have to be more prepared going in
you don't have three hours in the
morning to find the scene you can't fall
behind and schedule but we had the
luxury especially Sophie and I and ty as
well but Sophie and I probably had the
most rehearsal time together and like
she said it was like wasn't running the
scenes and playing the scene so much as
investigating the scenes and like you
know taking them apart and putting them
back together to make sure that they
were in the right place and right order
for a reason I would say the person who
I might have collaborated with in a
similar way the closest is Jessica
Chastain jess is just a friend and she's
someone who was coming to this
completely cold she'd never been in any
movie that really resembled this before
and so as opposed to my fuss bender and
James and Nick and Jen who we've made
this is now the fourth movie made I've
made with them Jessica had lots of
questions that started on the sort of
superficial science-fiction level and
then got deeper into the character or
emotional level and and that she had a
lot of thoughts and we crafted the look
together and her voicing and even the
way that we sort of approached her
character because she's many things in
this movie in terms of this sort of
roles she her character plays but she is
ultimately the villain of the film and
we talked about how to find a voice for
a villain that was unique and not like
you know moustache twirly because that's
not it's not something that Jessica
would be attracted to as a great actress
and she came up with this sort of
metaphor of like it's it's not fun
metaphor so I warn you in advance and
it's might make your husband cry too but
it's
of the veterinarian who has to give the
news that your dog needs to be put down
and in this case it's more than the dog
that needs to be put down from her point
of view but that kind of weird
calm eerie terrifying voicing was just
really different and way scarier than
her being shrill or being demonstrative
or aggressive and once she sort of found
her way into that it was like that
character locked it that's the kind of
voice that I get when there's been like
a horrible accident I turn into a robot
all of a sudden and I'm like where did
that come from
oh that's great that's one of the
fantastic things about Supergirl movies
these days is just that they're
significant
fantastic actors in these movies it's
not it's like you're getting like can
you talk about getting Jessica Chastain
in this new film because you know having
all these folks in the film and you know
people who couldn't be here today like
Foss bender and James McAvoy it's like
these are legit casts cast actually
Simon never really thought of anybody
else for that role and it wrote it for
her had no idea whether she'd really be
open to it
but it was one of those moments and as a
producer makes you nervous because if it
doesn't pan out it's inevitably a much
more disappointing moment John Malkovich
and you have a NASA Malkovich yet yeah
exactly right so but he did a really
great job on the on the script as it
said and and note knew the movie and the
ambition of the movie so well I think
was able to communicate all of that to
Jessica in in the language that makes
sense to her so so not that she was
actually opposed to these movies but I
think the threshold she maintained
for what it is she's interested in as an
actress is is extraordinarily high and
and I thought that's it that's true of
all the cast but but Jessica is I
believe you know it's not you know in
the top three actresses working today
maybe I mean she's just an extraordinary
actress so the bar was high and it
required Simon you know kind of show the
goods as the first-timer that's it's
challenging what you did yeah I uh I
look at these casts and I'm like you
know to grab you guys again and to grab
somebody you know all these other cast
members these movies have to be
intriguing on a different level so we've
reached just about the end of our time
today and before we go I would like for
each of you to choose an x-men that you
would like to be that is not you okay so
who of you who've you always related to
her whose power is awesome pick and give
an explanation and then we will allow
everybody to pull out their phones after
that it's an easy one for me uh magneto
oh one he was my favorite character
growing up - he's just a badass three
he's Jewish
and we don't have a representation in
comic books and he's just a complex
fascinating guy whose philosophy makes a
lot of sense but his actions maybe don't
and that's an interesting dichotomy so
but mostly because he's a badass too
I go back and forth but I think I think
in this moment I'm gonna recommit to
Wolverine because I mean and part of I'm
going to confess because of how long I
no longer relationship now I'm added
that character but but it's also because
I love the the mix of humanity and rage
that that coexists and and the struggle
that he undergoes in trying to work that
through to me is incredibly compelling
on a whole bunch of different levels and
the fact that in the end you can kick
your ass I really like to so the combo
is probably gonna lock me in there I
also like to think I'm just as ripped as
Wolverine bucks I don't know this is
something that you hutch said earlier in
another interview which I thought was
really interesting kind of going back
and forth between Professor X and
Magneto
in the way that they're kind of a bit
like MLK and Mun Malcolm X I feel like I
kind of go back and forth between them
striving to do the right thing but do it
doing it vastly different ways and can't
quite decide and feel like I'm either
one or the other
so I don't really know maybe I'm just
like gene actually I'm probably just to
also point out Wolverine could not
handle close proximity to a microwave
they had a man - I'm pretty sure like
pretty positive okay tie wrap it I'll do
it quickly Jim Gray she's just got it
going on
[Applause]